>>> ANXIETY GRIPPING THE
SOUTHERN UKRAINIAN CITY OF
KHERSON TONIGHT WHERE THERE ARE
CONFLICTING SIGNS OF A RUSSIAN
WITHDRAWAL AND FEAR OF WHAT
VLADIMIR PUTIN'S FORCES MIGHT
HAVE PLANNED NEXT.
CNN INTERNATIONAL DIPLOMATIC
EDITOR NIC ROBERTSON IS ON THE
SCENE IN UKRAINE FOR US.
NIC?
>> Reporter: ATOP KHERSON'S MAIN
GOVERNMENT BUILDING A CHANGE.
NO RUSSIAN FLAG.
ON A BUS NEARBY RESIDENTS CHEER,
REALIZING A RUSSIAN CHECKPOINT
IS GONE.
A CITY RESIDENT WHOM CNN IS NOT
IDENTIFYING FOR THEIR OWN
SECURITY DESCRIBES THE CHANGES.
"THERE'S NO LARGE ARMORED
VEHICLES IN THE CITY DURING THE
DAY," HE SAYS.
"AND ALL THE MILITARY
CHECKPOINTS IN THE CITY ARE
GONE."
"THE REGION'S RUSSIAN INSTALLED
GOVERNOR TOLD A RUSSIAN MEDIA
PROPAGANDIST RUSSIAN TROOPS ARE
HOLDING STEET FOR NOW BUT ADDED
"MOST LIKELY OUR TROOPS WILL
LEAVE FOR THE EAST BANK."
WHAT RUSSIA IS PLANNING, NOT
CLEAR.
UKRAINIAN OFFICIALS FEAR
DECEPTION.
>> Translator: WE SEE IT AND
REALIZE THAT THESE MAY BE
CERTAIN TRICKS, MILITARY
MANEUVERS TO BUILD CORRECT
DEFENSES AS THEY SEE IT.
NEVERTHELESS, WE SEE THAT IN
KHERSON THERE ARE STILL REGULAR
UNITS WEARING CIVILIAN CLOTHES.
>> Reporter: BUT UKRAINE STILL
CLAIMING GAINS.
THURSDAY DESTROYING SEVERAL
BOATS IN KHERSON PORT.
AND WEDNESDAY DESTROYING A
RUSSIAN SURFACE-TO-AIR MISSILE
SYSTEM.
OFTEN USED TO HIT UKRAINIAN
CIVILIANS IN NEARBY MYKOLAIV.
IN THE BLACK SEA TOO RUSSIA
APPEARS ON THE BACK FOOT AS
GRAIN SHIPMENTS RESUMED
FOLLOWING PUTIN'S REVERSAL OF
HIS REFUSAL THIS PAST WEEKEND TO
COOPERATE WITH THE U.N.-BROKERED
DEAL, CITING NEW GUARANTEES FROM
UKRAINE.
>> Translator: RUSSIA RESERVES
THE RIGHT TO WITHDRAW FROM THESE
AGREEMENTS IF THESE GUARANTEES
ARE BREACHED BY UKRAINE.
>> Reporter: ANOTHER SIGN,
ACCORDING TO UKRAINE'S
PRESIDENT, THAT PUTIN IS BEING
FORCED TO CHANGE.
>> Translator: 252 DAYS AGO
RUSSIA DEMANDED SECURITY
GUARANTEES FROM THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA.
AFTER EIGHT MONTHS OF THE
RUSSIAN SO-CALLED SPECIAL
OPERATION THE KREMLIN IS
DEMANDING SECURITY GUARANTEES
FROM UKRAINE.
>> Reporter: IN KHERSON PUTIN'S
INTENT STILL FAR FROM CLEAR.
RESIDENTS REPORT PLENTY OF
RUSSIAN HEAVY WEAPONS ON THE
EDGE OF THE CITY.
NOW, THE UKRAINIANS THEMSELVES
ARE WELL FAMILIAR WITH PULLING A
TRICK OR TWO ON THE RUSSIANS.
YOU REMEMBER A FEW WEEKS AGO THE
OUK RAINIANS MADE LIGHTNING
GAINS UP HERE IN THE NORTH.
WELL, PART OF THE WAY THEY DID
THAT WAS TO TRICK THE RUSSIANS
INTO THINKING THEY WERE GOING TO
ATTACK IN THE SOUTH.
THE RUSSIANS PUT REINFORCEMENTS
IN THE SOUTH AND THEN THE
UKRAINIANS TOOK THE TERRITORY IN
THE NORTH.
AND I THINK THE OTHER THING IN
PLAY HERE THAT UKRAINIANS KNOW,
KHERSON IS SO IMPORTANT TO
PUTIN.
IT'S GOING TO BE A HUGE
EMBARRASSMENT IF AND WHEN HE
LOSES IT.
QUITE SIMPLY, IT'S A CAPITAL OF
ONE OF THE FOUR PR